okay all right so it's like 5:30 in the
morning and I'm gonna start to get ready
because today's spinned a spin day yeah
so we need a lot of energy first good
day I actually really enjoy spinning
it's just you know tired I'm a week out
from a wedding a little bit stressed but
this is a good stress reliever so there
is no skipping workouts at this point in
the game and oh my god I get we gotta
get going so I'm going to go make a
little coffee and for this brush my
teeth and I'll meet at the gym hey guys
I'm already in the spin room and always
the first one here except I'd like to do
a little pre workout warm-up to get
ready for the killer road ahead I'm
already out of breath so I guess that's
a good sign so I'll catch you when I'm
really hot red and sweaty and we'll do a
little pose for kids snack Hey see that
hey guys so I just got out of my spin
class this is what a badass workout
looks like really red really sweaty I'm
exhausted but I feel great and I'm so
ready for a little post-workout snack so
come back to my kitchen and I'm going to
show you what I'm going to eat
okay guys I'm all recovered after my
first spin workout I've already answered
some emails and run a few little morning
errands and I'm ready to make a quick
breakfast
so I just finished up my weight training
session with my trainer I try to see him
about three times a week on the same
days that I do my spinning or my cardio
so I'm not doubling up on the weights
and I'm starving right now so I'm gonna
go make myself a little something for
for lunch blend that's really high in
protein that of course is going to
refuel after that workout so let's go
through it
so here I am again I know I looking a
little different than I was before
but we've been filling some Abbie's
kitchen videos here today and I'm just
getting ready to set up for another one
so this is real time I need a quick
little bit of energy a nice little snack
to get me through the next few few
recipes so I'm going to get to that
right now
so we're just wrapping up we're just
cleaning everything up and getting all
the food put away but I need a little
quick something something to get me
through the rest of this cleanup so I'm
going to go make my hub with quick
little snap hey guys so I'm about to
have a little dinner so I'm going to
make something for myself and I know
you're probably thinking that girls
eating so many times for the day and I
know I am I'm eating frequently because
of course the last week before my
wedding and I'm working out more so I
need to fuel those workouts and I think
that's one of the big mistakes that a
lot of brides make is that they cut
calories so low by the time they get to
the honeymoon
they totally rebound because the
metabolism is so shot so I haven't done
that I've really focused on getting
really good quality food in and feeling
satiated and just feeling good and it's
working so I'm going to make my little
meal here and I'll see you soon
surprise fries guys snack number three I
love baby bells I always have baby bells
in the fridge for an easy quick snack
and I'm gonna really enjoy
hey guys so I'm just getting ready to
finish up my last snack of the night
this is a little cottage cheese with
tons of almonds on top and some toasted
coconut such a great snack it is loaded
with casein protein which is a really
slow digesting protein so it keeps me
fuller longer which I really think is
great and I wake up hangry and you know
I hope you really enjoyed my little what
I eat a date a week before my wedding
it's going to be fun I'm going to
definitely do another one of these when
I get back from the honeymoon so that
you can kind of see how I incorporate
healthy foods into my everyday balanced
diet when I'm not trying to fit into a
really tight backless not forgiving
dress if you know what I mean
also what the thing I want you to know
is this whole time I still be eating out
and enjoying myself I mean even just the
other day I went in for dinner I had
dessert a head of beer it doesn't mean
you cannot enjoy yourself so it's all
about you know moderation and balance so
I hope you guys like this if you did
please give me a thumbs up leave me a
comment below about of course what
you're making for dinner and what you're
eating today subscribe to my channel and
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
good night
you